Okay, this next story is so damn funny that
it's actually difficult for me to put into
words.
Marianne Williamson is running for the 20
Democratic presidential nomination.
She has no chance.
I mean, she's polling so low that she's not
even in the top 20 candidates in recent polling
summaries.
Now she's a little bit wacky.
She has a long history of being a sort of
new age self help guru.
I've interviewed her on the program before,
but she also has lots of completely reasonable
and and mainstream left wing views, which,
uh, I agree with and many of the people in
our audience would agree with.
There is also a cultural critic and arbiter
of big ideas named Dave Rubin who is all about
discussing ideas and he's like a sort of center
right kind of guy.
Uh, and he interviewed Marianne Williamson
and she truly made him look so uninformed
and did it so easily.
Like without even breaking a sweat with no
visible effort debunking all of Dave Rubin's
attempts to put her in some sort of current
corner.
And it was really a pleasure to watch.
So I want to look at a couple of these with
you.
One popular sort of a meme or false notion
that the right has been pushing is that we
should be giving Donald Trump credit because
he decided not to bomb Iran.
And it's such a dumb talking point because
if it ignores the reality that Trump is the
one who made the decision to bomb Iran in
the first place and then he radically canceled
it last minute after someone said, hey, you
know, 150 people are likely to die because
of this.
Right?
And Bernie Sanders had a really good analogy
on this when he was asked, shouldn't Trump
get credit for not bombing run up?
Bernie said, this is like if you set a trashcan
on fire and then you put the fire out and
you say, hey everybody, I did a great thing.
I put the trashcan fire out.
It's like, well, you set the fire in the first
place, so what kind of credit do you really
deserve for that?
So Marianne Williamson destroys this talking
point easily points out that Trump is pulling
us from the nuclear deal that Trump's pulling
us from the nuclear deal.
Better said was the real problem.
I know you wouldn't want to give it to him,
but does Trump deserves some credit for not
doing that strike?
If he got a, he got a call a minute before
and you know 120 people, you're going to get
killed.
Credit in terms of Iran?
No, it was the president who got, who recklessly
removed us from the Iran nuclear deal.
That is what led up to that.
The president taking us out of the Iran nuclear
deal out of a situation that was an intranational
leveraging where by all indicators, Iran was
that we know of that Iran was combined.
So now they've said the other day that they're
going to go on and enrich uranium beyond what
the agreement called for.
Cause we had pulled out, no, I cannot give
the president any credit for what's happening
with Iran.
The fact that he was about to do something
so an unbelievably reckless, because let me
tell you something.
Given the size of the Iranian army alone,
you think Iraq was a catastrophe?
Nothing compared to what war with Iran would
look like.
So obviously some hero, we don't know exactly
what it was, but we know someone within the
higher echelons of either his administration,
his national security apparatus or the military,
talked him out of it, that we can be very
thankful to this person, whoever they were.
This is really fun.
I have to admit, I love watching these clips.
It's just so, so funny to watch the breakdown
because you've got Kooky Marianne Williamson
just easily exposing the absurdity of these
questions from Dave Rubin.
So here's another one.
Another one of these ideas that sort of being
pushed on Democrats is the idea that the democratic
2020 presidential candidates are for open
borders.
And of course not a single Democrat has said
anything about open borders.
And this is so funny because when Marianne
Williamson points it out, Dave Ruben says,
well, okay, they're not saying they're for
open borders, but it sort of seems like that's
what their policies are all about and Marianne
Williamson is just having none of it.
Okay, a couple more quick.
We'll try to do them quick.
A, it seems like everyone's kind of veering
to some version of open borders that that's
somehow something kind of, so tell me, well,
I don't get to that.
I don't consider myself a Democrat and I don't
consider myself a Republican, but I'm definitely
not a democrat.
I have not heard one candidate, well they
won't say it, but the policies seem, don't
say it, but you relate me is that is that
healthy, honorable debate?
Of course, no one has said anything about
open borders policies and this is actually
what they say we're not supposed to do.
When it comes to saying people that are racist
except here, it's really a cut and dry policy
thing.
So let me explain what I mean by that.
The right loves to say, even if someone says
something that sounds racially insensitive
or it could be xenophobic or racist, you don't
really know what's in their mind.
So you can't call them racist.
You don't know their true motivations for
saying that thing.
That might sound racist.
So you shouldn't call them racist.
Here, Dave Rubin is saying, okay, even though
no one has actually said they want open borders,
it's okay to infer that they are for open
borders apparently, because what?
They're against the Cajun kids at the border,
they're against deporting DACA recipients
who were brought to the United States by their
parents through no fault of their own when
they were minors.
And then lastly, Dave Rubin tries to, I guess,
call out Marianne Williamson for making an
analogy between, uh, the Holocaust and slavery
in the United States as horrible, horrible
events, which is funny because the right claims
to be against the oppression Olympics.
This is one of their big things.
The right says, Oh, you know, I'm against
ranking oppressive events.
I'm against ranking what group, what demographic
group is more or less oppressed or deserving
of help in society?
Okay, fine.
But here is Marianne Williamson who seems
to have to explain that to Dave Rubin.
Well will, do you think there's a little bit
of a risk in sort of, I mean a couple of times
you're referencing the genocide of the Jews
to slavery seems like a little
bit of a slippery slope
there.
No, I don't even know how we can say that
actually.
And I say that as a Jew, have you read up
much on slavery?
Yeah, we're talking abject slavery day.
I mean, nobody's in a contest.
Nobody has a monopoly on human suffering.
This was abject slavery.
There's always a risk to equating civil rights.
Catastrophe is because it's true that there,
there's no two events that are exactly the
same.
Events take places, uh, events take place
in different places and at different times
in history.
So to say two events are the same or basically
the same or mean the same thing.
It's a little bit risky, but American slavery
was one of the worst thing that's happened.
And the Holocaust is one of the worst things
that has happened in human history on this
planet.
So this may have been like the best possible
thing to ever happen to Marianne Williamson's
campaign.
She's still polling at zero.
Uh, and it doesn't even seem like that many
people have seen this interview, but it was
really a pleasure to watch and I got some
emails after the last debate.
This, this is really weird.
After the, the democratic debate a few weeks
ago, I got some emails from people saying,
Hey David, I think Marianne Williamson actually
did the best in the debate.
I think Maryann won the debate.
Here's links to some youtubers who agree with
me.
And I was certain it had to be some kind of
satirical thing like back when Howard Stern's
audience was trying to vote for son Jaya,
a candidate on American idol, even though
the kid couldn't sing just because it would
be funny to support someone who has no idea
what's going on.
But apparently it was real and a lot of people
actually seem to be claiming that in Syria
in some kind of serious way.
Marianne Williamson won that first debate.
She holds some of the right positions on a
number of issues, but she is a quite out there
and certainly not somebody I could see getting
behind given the other people that are in
the 2020 democratic slate of possibilities.
Let me know what you think.
Make sure you're following me on Instagram
at [inaudible].
David got pacman and while you're there, follow
the David Pakman flow on Instagram at David
Todd to [inaudible] right back up there,